et
il ya quelques années j'ai retrouvé un
job chez viadeo en tant que 6e au patron
des opérations à paris et comme j'habite
grenoble je me suis pris un petit
appartement pas loin de viadeo au dessus
de notre dame de lorette dans le 9e de
sorte que je puisse aller travailler à
pied et à paris qu'on vous allez
travailler à pied vous marchez dix
minutes sur un trottoir vous rencontrez
5 6 7 10 parfois personnes qui dorment
là sur le trottoir qui vivent dans la
rue alors qu'on peut appeler des sans
abri des personnes sdf etc
et comme j'ai pas d'amis bains en
passant le matin je leur parle donc on
se dit bonjour on apprend à se connaître
et connaissent mon prénom je connais le
leur et voilà le temps passe une
relation s'établit peut-être six mois
après on était début de l'hiver 2012
je vais travailler un peu tôt j'avais
une réunion qui démarrait tout le matin
il faisait froid il commence à pleuvoir
et je tombe sur une de ces personnes
qu'on va appeler robert s'est pas
vraiment son nom qui pleurait et en fait
d'habitude et la patate c'est à dire
qu'il est toujours la pêche il dort il
dort là par terre dans la rue mais ça
allait bien quoi hélas il était vraiment
désespéré dont je m'arrête une humilité
ce qui active apa est une diva regarde
et il me montre ses dents et et tout
casser
il venait de se faire très violemment
agressé pendant la nuit et il n'y avait
pratiquement plus une seule dent qui
était qui était en place quoi donc je
suis dit coûte
là c'est grave quoi je vais appeler les
secours il refuse et bien souvent les
personnes sdf en fait tu refuses pour
ceux qui connaissent un petit peu le
secteur refusent les services d'urgence
de cet état
il était vraiment désespéré parce qu'il
disait mais qu'est ce que je vais
devenir si je peux même pas manger mon
sandwich et du coup son problème c' est
devenu le mien parce qu'évidemment je
peux pas être sympa quand tout va bien
et que la tipp et puis va lui dire tu
que tu comprends j'ai un boulot et j'ai
une réunion qui démarre quoi
donc comment on fait quand on est dans
la rue à 8 heures du matin qu'on connaît
pas les services je connais pas le guide
de solidarité de la ville de paris on
sait pas les associations qui peuvent
traiter ça donc le réflexe est
d'utiliser mon téléphone et je dis
twitter est ce que tu pourrais me
trouver un dentiste dans le 9e
arrondissement qui accepteraient de
soigner une personne sdf en urgence donc
ça a fonctionné en fait j'ai reçu un sms
d'un ami appelle ma dentiste l'appeler
elle voulait pas répondre ne voulais pas
le prendre mais vous êtes qui s'est
enfin j'arrive à négocier un rendez vous
je vais voir robert il faut pas violer
là si on avait pu être deux ça aurait
été bien de l connaître et dire écoute
maintenant on vient parce que bref j'ai
dit non tu me lâches pas là dessus j'ai
pris un rendez vous on y va donc je
l'emmène la dentiste lui mais des
antibiotiques des antidouleurs elle se
prend d'affection pour lui ai dit
écoutez moi je propose il faut l'opérer
il ya trois ans attire l on pourra plus
rien en faire je fais l'opération
gratuitement ensuite on va lui faire des
prothèses donc il lui montre les
prothèses et je vais faire les prothèses
gratuitement là elle se tourne
d'ailleurs moi elle m'a dit ouais mais
par contre si je le perds c'est le début
de l'hiver faux pas qui danse dans la
rue après l'opération donc trouver lui
un logement là pour une semaine
comment on fait donc là j'ai utilisé de
nouveau mon téléphone avec un carnet de
contacts en disant tiens je connais
vaguement romain qui a monté il ya
quinze ans une asso pour s'occuper des
sdf j'appelle romain quiniou l'appel
etienne il a fait une association qui
fait de la colocation avec des sdf
j'appelle etienne etienne il dit ouais
moi je fais ça mais à lyon mont capell
martin je l'appelle martin et martin il
répond pas je tombe sur un répondeur
donc j'ai échoué j'ai échoué alors entre
2 et robert quand la douleur était
soigné et plus trop envie qu'on lui
arrache ses dents et dans les mois qui
ont suivi j'ai eu pas mal d'expérience
de ce type là un autre qui se fait voler
son sac avec ses papiers non sans
saccades mois a retrouvé des papiers je
le droit d'être en france parce que je
suis européen
une femme qui était battu en france le
système institutionnel fonctionne à bien
on est dans un des pays où la solidarité
fonctionne bien et les
institutionnaliser on a des mécanismes
de redistribution qui tourne à plein
régime
martin hirsch qui était au commissaire
aux solidarités lgv elle explique dans
un de ses livres vous avez la citation
là et pourtant en disant il n'y a plus
de 50 % de personnes dans la rue donc le
chiffre a explosé le lien social avec
eux est rompu c'est à dire qu'ils
souffrent d'un dans une absence totale
de liens avec plus de toi tu travailles
une relation etc
et du coup il ya un tout en tissu
associatif qui est en place qui fait un
superbe travail pour les aider à manger
à se loger à essayer de retrouver des
logements d'insertion sociale de leur
trouver de quoi stocker les bagages etc
etc
et le plus important ce qui leur manque
le plus cruellement c'est le lien c'est
la relation
c'est ce qui fait leur dignité en fait
c'est le fait qu'on les connaisse on les
reconnaît ce qu'on leur parle on soit en
lien avec une considération un petit peu
d'attention khadr tous les matins il va
acheter son journal
chez le kiosquier simplement pour avoir
le bon jour comprenez ça compte
un bon jour cyril me dis je vois pas ces
3000 personnes tous les jours devant moi
il y en a deux qui me disent bonjour
pierrot lui contant sandwich il me dit
un bonjour ça vaut 100 sandwich quoi la
vision d' entourage
c'est donc que ces personnes qui vivent
dans la rue ont besoin d'être entouré
dans la bienveillance
si possible par leurs voisins qui pourra
casser la spirale de cet isolement et
les sortir de là des personnes proches
ça c'est la vision de d'entourage la
question c'est comment on peut réussir à
faire ça comment réussir à reconnecter
la rue des personnes qui vivent avec les
habitants les riverains etc
et du coup on s'est intéressé au
pourquoi ça se passe pas quoi pourquoi
on rentre pas dans cette relation la
plupart du temps avec ces personnes qui
sont dans la rue et donc on s'intéresse
aux blocages aux peurs aux préjugés au
sentiment d'être tout seul dans la
relation
peut-être de ne pas savoir comment faire
de pas connaître les associations qui
s'en occupe
sentiment de la goutte d'eau et puis
devient mais je moi je ne saurais pas
quoi faire quoi et du coup on s'est dit
comment réussir à passer en adressant
ces questions là qui sont légitimes
en créant le premier réseau collaboratif
géolocalisées sur smartphone pour venir
quelque part en relation avec ceux qui
n'ont plus rien donc voilà ça c'est
l'idée d' entourage du coup dans cette
application qui se trouve sur le
smartphone du riverain
on va lui mettre l'information les
éléments du guide de solidarité de son
quartier géolocalisation une carte on va
le mettre en relation avec les
associations de de son village de son
quartier de son secteur
on va le mettre en relation grâce à la
technologie avec les autres riverains
qui ne connaît pas forcément dans son
quartier qui sont en lien avec robert
avec les personnes de la rue et qui sont
prêts à aider à ce que beaucoup de monde
et de fait prêt à aider on va également
trouver des contributeurs individuel
professionnelle qui va pouvoir dire moi
j'offre une temps en temps une fois fin
juin
je suis coiffeur je vais offrir une
coiffure gratuite ou une coupe de
cheveux un dermato un opticien un
boulanger et c'est donc des
contributeurs qui vont aussi pouvoir
spontanément agir dans ce réseau du coup
on est relativement bien armé pour
construire ce réseau parce que j'avais
dans une expérience passée une vie
antérieure était le site i o de kelkoo
qui était un des grands succès du
e-commerce au début des années 2000
qu'on a vendu à yahoo en 2004 j'étais
devenu vice président dia ou pour leurs
ingénieries en europe
après ça j'ai pas mal contribué à
investir cet argent gagné dans un
certain nombre de start-up en france
d'accompagner des jeunes entrepreneurs
je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait on
avait beaucoup innové depuis 20 ans dans
ce qu'on appelle maintenant la french
tech c'est à dire qu'on était venu avec
des solutions innovantes en amenant des
nouvelles technologies sur sur des tas
de problèmes un peu que tout le monde se
pose quoi donc dans la question du
commerce dont la presse qui a été
discuté et les transports les voyages
récemment les taxis donc on avait amené
toute cette intelligence collective à
amener des solutions innovantes dans des
domaines de la vie de tous les jours on
est servi tous les jours mais la french
tech et là je lance un appel pour axel
le maire quoi on sait pas encore
intéressés au domaine social
on n'a pas à appliquer ses idées
d'innovation pour les exclus pour les
personnes qui n'ont rien et donc on
appelle les acteurs de la french tech a
inventé ce qu'on l'appelle chez
entourage la technologie positive tire
cette technologie qui va être au service
de l'homme et au service des humains
donc la peine à marcher très vite donc
en 2014 quand j'ai lancé cette idée j'ai
été rejoint par un tas de sociétés qui
ont dit mais nous on le fait ton truc
quoi en mécénat de compétences on va
venir télé on a des talents de
communicant d'ingénieurs de graphistes
et c'est pas mal de bénévoles
professionnels de la french tech qui qui
m'ont rejoint donc on a déposé les
statuts de l'association il ya juste un
an en novembre 2014 quelques fondations
aussi qu'ils ont commencé à nous aider
parce qu'il faut quand même un petit peu
d'argent pour faire ça et on a sorti fin
septembre
mr version bêta test c'est une première
étape qui permet d'équiper pour
l'instant les associations du secteur
c'est-à-dire les associations qui font
des tournées rue qui font les marolles
qui vont au contact avec les personnes
delà de la rue donc on a créé une
plateforme qui s'appelle open maraude
sur laquelle les associations
participent et en parallèle on est en
train de travailler donc ça c'est en
cours de déploiement et on est en train
de travailler en parallèle avec les
ingénieurs pour développer la version
grand public qui j'espère sera
disponible
un peu au début de l'année prochaine
donc voilà entourage vous l'avez compris
c'est pas un réseau dead c'est pas un
réseau de signalements d'alert un réseau
d aide matérielle dans lesquels on
s'auto organisent pour amener à manger
quoi c'est un réseau de relations
si possible de relation d'égal à égal
c'est dire que la relation à l'humanise
la relation elle redonne la dignité aux
deux parties et l'humanise les deux
partis d'ailleurs quand vous rentrez en
relation avec quelqu'un qui a exclu sur
le bord de la route
bah évidemment où il fait du bien parce
que vous lui apportez de considération
de l'affection de la tension là la
preuve qu'il existe mais vous peut-être
vous êtes débarrassé de certaines
certitudes
vous avez dû franchir une certaine peur
donc franchir vos barrières de sécurité
certains préjugés parfois aussi et ça
fait du bien en fait quand on casse
comme ça c'est sécurité quand on teste
ses préjugés et qu'on va contacter la
personne la plus pauvre dans la rue
souvent tendance à dire qu'elle vit
l'instant présent parce que son futur il
n'est pas brillant pour elle donc elle
pas trop dans le futur parce que pour
elle son futur elle le voit pas quoi et
puis le passé les douloureux il est fait
de pas mal de galères de de violence
souvent de chute des chèques etc
psychologiquement elle a pas trop de
choix éléments présents déjà faut
survivre
donc elle est là elle est présente et
vous savez bien que nous le présent en
fait on fuit en permanence parce que
c'est une fuite de soi donc ont fui dans
notre activisme le fuite dans nos super
progrès de demain de ce qu'on va faire
etc
ou alors on se remémore notre passé et
puis on sera content mais on est très
peu dans le présent en réalité et quand
vous allez à la rencontre avec ces
personnes de la rue vous allez vous
rendre compte que vous allez être
ramenés dans votre présent et ce
présentiel là c'est ce qui fait de
l'être et donc ça fait du bien quand
vous êtes dans la rue vous êtes exposés
vous êtes nu vous êtes dépendant des
autres quoi y'a pas moyen vraiment de se
cacher je peux pas mettre un masque en
disant voilà j'ai pas de masque social
quoi je peux pas me cacher derrière ma
profession derrière je ne sais pas
quelle réussite sociale sportive
artistique ou je sais pas quoi je suis
moi même j'ai rien quoi donc magie est
tenu
et vous savez que nous on adore se
donner des masques on adore se
construire voilà je me suis présenté
avec ma profession tout à l'heure donc
on voit là puis on aime bien dire je
suis père de famille ou voilà je suis et
la relation qu'on a les uns avec les
autres c'est des relations de masques à
masquer quoi est fait l'expérience vous
allez en relation avec ces personnes
dans la rue qui n'ont rien et en
particulier pas de masse parce qu'elles
peuvent pas se le permettre
le vôtre tombe vous avez pas lui dire je
banquier je suis ou alors si vous avez
lu dire c'est juste pour dire ok ça ne
m'est pas très différente toit en
réalité quoi
voilà donc je voudrais vous demander ça
va être ma conclusion ne pas attendre de
se saisir de vous saisir du problème et
d'agir ne pas attendre parce que c'est
pas l'état qui va régler ce problème là
c'est pas les institutions d'abord il en
aurait pas les moyens de le faire c'est
vraiment à chacun d'entre nous de se
saisir de cette question de la personne
qui nous est confiée c'est à dire que la
personne que je croise tous les matins
quand je vais travailler devant la salle
de gym ou demain on travaille devant
chez moi c'est ma responsabilité en fait
donc chacun d'entre nous on peut faire
quelque chose et on doit faire quelque
chose et encore une fois ça nous fera du
bien
il faut se dire que collectivement on a
une force énorme c'est à dire qu'on est
capable de transformer les mentalités et
si on se met ça dans la tête et qu'on
agit cirk ont quelque part on fracasse
ces barrières un peu de nos peurs et nos
préjugés pour aller dans cette relation
vous verrez c'est vraiment gagnant
gagnant c'est important de comprendre
qu'en fait on est tous pauvres parce que
la vraie pauvreté c'est quoi c'est
d'être dépendant des autres et sarah
impôts c'est quelqu'un qui est dépendant
des autres pour tous et le riche est
celui qui a pas besoin des autres et la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on est tous
pauvres parce qu'on est tous dépendants
les uns des autres c'est ce qui fait de
nous vraiment des humains donc voilà je
vous demande de passer à l'action
les personnes sdf ont froid toute
l'année dans la rue elles ont froid de
notre indifférence et c'est à nous c'est
à vous de les entourer d'un peu de
chaleur et nana je vous remercie
beaucoup